with the new air pots Pro it seems like
Apple is attacking every single thing
that people complained about with the
original air pods so in this review
we'll see if Apple succeeded let me
first remind you of the main problems
people had with the air pots
first off quite a few people have ear
canals that simply don't fit the air
pods like my brother-in-law Ben who
absolutely loves Apple products but air
pods just won't fit in his ears a lot of
people also felt that the sound quality
of the air pods was lacking for the
price especially the bass reproduction
and people didn't really like the
long-stem design in fact they still say
it looks like a toothbrush hanging out
of your ear there were also connection
and lag issues which thankfully were
fixed with air pots to in its new h1
chip which is the same chip that's also
packed into the pros so that's fixed
people complained about no noise
cancellation and since the older air
pods don't have a seal design there's
already a lot of sound leakage I
personally was disappointed with the
lack of controls on the air pods being
limited to two control options and
having to double tap the air pods which
worked decently well but when it didn't
it was extremely annoying other than
that the air pods were always great and
very reliable becoming the best-selling
wireless earphones in the world and now
we've got the ear pods Pro so let's see
if Apple fix those issues starting with
the new design yes the new case is
larger but not large enough to make it
an inconvenience it still fits perfectly
fine in my small pocket within a pocket
so don't worry about the case at all the
new design of the air pods is definitely
different with new black vents and
details all the way around so it's
pretty easy to tell that sone is wearing
the pros and not the regular ear pods
especially since the stem has been
shortened by quite a bit making it look
a bit nicer and it also stops the stem
from rubbing against your skin if you
didn't put them in at the correct angle
I love the Apple includes three
different sizes of silicone ear tips and
they even have an ear tip fit test to
make sure they seal well but I'd
recommend trying all of them out because
we got better bass with the largest tips
even though the median ones pass a test
Apple has done something truly
YOUnique with these silicone tips almost
every single in ear earphone I've ever
used has a thin protruding plastic tube
for the speakers that actually goes into
your ear canal alongside the silicone
tips and not long after wearing
earphones like that my ears would start
to hurt from the plastic insert and
that's part of the reason why I switched
to Apple earpods
many years ago but with the pros the
speaker grille is actually flush with
the pro itself so only the soft silicone
tip goes into your ear that means your
ears literally won't hurt at all even
after hours of use and even better the
tips include their own little plastic
grille so ear wax or anything else will
never get into the actual speaker grille
itself unlike the original ear pods
which were really annoying to clean and
could actually lower the sound quality
so with the air pod pros just take off
the silicone tip rinse it dry it and
it's perfectly clean and because of this
design it allows the pros to have a
massive speaker grille especially
compared to other recently released in
ear earphones which makes it much easier
to recreate a wide soundstage of
frequencies the air pod pros feature of
vents on the outside that lets an air so
that the pressure inside your ears
actually matches the pressure of the
outside world so even though they're
using a sealed in ear design they don't
plug your ears like basically every
other in ear earphone does so they feel
just as free and comfortable as they did
before almost like they're not even
there it's seriously the best of both
worlds and you really have to try it for
yourself to understand how great this
feature is the pros also have a new
force touch sensor that replaces the old
double tap design for controls and so
far I'm extremely happy with the change
its accurately registered in my presses
every single time so far and it's super
sensitive and quick with no lag time in
an audible click each time you press so
it's much more reliable than the double
tap method I especially like that you
have so many more options now allowing
you to play and pause skip forward skip
back and switch between noise
cancellation modes all on one air pod
pro with the original air pods you
literally had to pick and choose just
one control for each side and to make it
even better you can go into your
bluetooth
settings on your iPhone tap the I icon
next to your air pod pros and
individually change the press and hold
commands for each side now before I get
into sound quality I want to talk about
noise cancellation if you've never tried
it before
it'll literally blow your mind when you
turn it on any background noise like the
air conditioning just disappears with
the old air pods I'd have to max out the
volume to drown out any background noise
but then basically everyone around you
can hear what you're listening to what's
great about the noise cancellation is
that it now allows you to listen to
music at much lower volumes while in
noisy environments and the transparency
mode is amazing it uses the microphone
to basically record your surroundings
and then the speakers play all of it
directly into your ears Apple absolutely
nailed it with the volume balanced in
this mode because with it on like it is
right now you can actually forget that
you're wearing them and in terms of how
well the noise reduction works larger
over the ear headphones like the Sony WH
1000 m3s do a better job because they
obviously have much more power so in the
past you definitely want to take those
with you onto an airplane while
traveling but to be completely honest
the noise reduction on the air pod pros
are more than good enough to be able to
leave those large Sony's behind in a big
surprise to me was that the pros
actually have better sound quality than
those 350 dollar Sony's now they're not
as loud or as Spacey but the quality
itself is actually better and it's
noticeably better compared to the old
airport the dynamic range or separation
of low medium and high frequencies
improved over the air pods too you can
easily hear and distinguish every
instrument nothing gets blended together
like you get with a lot of other
earphones out there the bass now feels
very deep rich and accurate compared to
before in vocal reproduction is
incredibly clear along with bright highs
that no longer sound blaringly loud
tinny or distorted at maximum volume and
that's because of the inward-facing
microphone that literally listens for
distortion and automatically reaches the
frequencies of the sound to make sure
that there is no distortion and even
though it does this the pros are still
more than loud enough especially with
the added noise reduction
there's
songs that I used to play that have very
specific high notes that would always
make my speakers distort like the song
strobe by deadmau5 so I replayed those
songs on the air pod pros and it
actually tuned those frequencies to get
rid of the distortion that's just insane
the best and my favorite part about this
feature is that two years down the line
when other earphones will usually
degrade in quality and start distorting
at high volumes the air pot pros
shouldn't the inward-facing microphone
is also used for the new adaptive EQ
feature which analyzes how the sound
bounces off the inside of your ear canal
and then Tunes it to the specific shape
of your ear sort of like how sound
engineers tune the sound in IMAX movie
theatres to the shape of the theater
room to make sure it sounds amazing for
the audience so Apple is using this
incredible software combined with three
different sizes of ear tips to make sure
that each and every person experiences
awesome sound quality no matter how big
or oddly shaped their ear canals are
with all that said I can safely say that
yes Apple actually fixed basically every
major issue that people had with the
original ear pods and they added a bunch
of awesome new features like noise
cancellation and ipx4 sweat and water
resistance so if you're still trying to
figure out if spending the extra cash on
the air Potts Pro is worth it over the
air pods - I would say that if there's
any way possible that you can stretch
your budget enough to get the air pods
pro do it by them and never look back
because I honestly think that Apple has
absolutely nailed it with the air pods
pro if you enjoy this review tap the
like button and check out the air paws
Pro versus air pods - full comparison
video right over there and if you're not
already soft click that circle above
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]